today
we're gonna learn about um ohm's law
i'm curious how many of you have heard
of or know about ohm's law
i know i do
oh yeah yeah yeah i've heard about it
yeah
so the simplest way it is represented is
uh v equals ir
that is um the voltage drop or the
potential drop across
a resistor in this case is just the
current
um that passes through the resistor
times its current so
if we were to draw a resistor right here
with a value
r and this is the current then the
voltage drop
across um this resistor
this v is equal to the current times
that resistor value that
the resistor has so the resistance value
of the resistor and the current pass
that passes through it
current is the flow of electrons and v
is
the potential so think of it as a
um a force essentially
that allows or enables these electrons
to move from
um an area of higher potential to a low
lower potential
so if you guys have drunk boba before
what happens is in the cup you guys have
these bobas at the bottom
and when you try to at the end once
you're done with your drink you're
trying to
um suck these bobas up uh
the when you're um
trying to suck these uh bubbles out of
this straw
the pressure that you're putting on to
it is essentially analogous to this
voltage
and the flow of these bubbles in this
straw is essentially like the current
and the resistance is essentially the
friction of these bubbles with this
straw and that is the pressure you would
need to overcome
the flow of these bubbles in this straw
against this friction to to get it this
is essentially analogous to that
so what we are doing is essentially this
oh sorry about that this concept is
pretty much
um uh described in almost
every high school and high school
physics and
early college physics but a lot of
people have a hard time
using this in real life so one of the
ways we can use it
is if we have a simple circuit
so if we have a simple circuit and
we have an led here
so essentially these are little light
bulb
looking things that emit light
when you drive a current through them so
they
light up so in a circuit like this
um what happens is we have a potential
drop or a voltage source
right here let's say it is 2 volts
and there is a resistor right here and
we need a current to flow through this
led to light it up
so right here i have a red led that i'll
show you guys in a minute
but red leds have a current
rating of 20 milliamps
and in order to make a circuit where we
can
light up this red led we need to know
what should be this resistor value
for the current in the circuit to be
exactly this current
that this led needs to turn on
okay so we will be finding this
resistor value to do this and
this is a real life application for
example if you want to turn on this led
so we will need to use ohm's law right
here v equals ir
to to do this and we know the voltage
2 volts and we know the current that is
20 milliamps
so if the current is 20 milliamps
what would the resistor value be
100 exactly
so now we will use this in a circuit and
see if our led turns on
um so i'll share my
camera with you guys and
see if this works can you guys see me
now
yes uh-huh
so now
okay so now what we have is
a circuit
can you guys see the circuit yeah we
will be
not worrying about this part of the
circuit for now so the only thing we
worry that
we worry about is um so there is a two
volts
input right here in this port
and we found out a resistor value of 100
ohms will do the job so this is a 100
ohms resistor
and we will plug this in from a 2 volt
source
in this breadboard so this is a
breadboard if you guys have
dealt with prototyping electronics you
might have used this
um it's just a bunch of holes that are
connected to each other so all these
five holes in a row
are connected to each other and the
columns are not connected so you can use
them to essentially make your circuit
so we will be connecting that there and
we will be using a red led
this is an led and this one is a red one
and um leds have
two legs essentially the longer one is
the positive one
because they're directional and if you
connect them the opposite way they don't
turn on
so the longer leg will go to positive
which is connected to the resistor
essentially and then the negative one
will go to ground
so we will connect this right here
and we will connect the other leg
to i can't see it oh
sorry yeah so we will connect the other
leg to
ground over here so
yeah so ground right here
so uh in this breadboard i've set up
this rail at the bottom
so this negative the blue rail is uh
ground
and the positive rail is the positive
volt that i'll connect the battery to
and i have a voltage divider setup right
here
that i will explain in a minute but this
essentially
takes my battery which is nine volts
this is a nine volt battery and divides
this into
essentially the required voltage that i
need and that is two volts right here
that will go into the resistor
so we will connect this battery now and
see
if it works
can you guys see
there we go so we will have a closer
i will connect the battery
connected battery pin
do you see that
yes the red led turns on so
um this is a real life application of
this so
uh of ohm's law we can use it to turn on
leds you can use it for your personal
projects
or anything like that you can buy leds
they're very cheap
and you can set up the circuitry on your
own
and make an led turn on and do a lot of
other cool things with it
now leds have any questions so far
no okay so now leds have
um different current rating essentially
if you're turning on a red one you need
a different current to go through it and
if you are turning on a blue one
you would need a different current to go
through it
so um a blue one so this one needs
uh 20 milliamps to go through it to turn
on a blue one will need 30 milliamps to
go
through it to turn on do you guys think
if i switch
this red led with a blue one would it
turn on right now
uh probably not exactly it will not turn
on because
uh because we set up the circuit for a
20
milliamp current which is lower than the
30 milliamp
current and that's why the blue one will
not turn on we can uh
test this and here i have a blue led
i mean we can
okay we can plug in the blue led
okay now i can plug in the battery and
see if it works
oh battery is connected but the blue led
does not turn on
where it's very dim yeah i don't think
it's on at all
so in order to do this to make the blue
led turn on what do you guys think the
resistor value should be
we know the voltage is 2 volts we know
the current to be 30 milliamps
what should the resistor value be
although versus this one by two thirds
exactly something like 67 ohms
um so if you plug in that we
can turn on the blue led
so now i will um go on to the concept of
the voltage divider which essentially is
the reason we can take the
9 volt battery and connect it to it
without burning anything down
and that is essentially when resistors
are in series that is they're connected
to each other
they divide the voltage that goes
through them
think of it as having two bubbles in
your straw
when you are trying to pull out the
bubbles at the bottom of your boba drink
if you have two bubbles and destroy you
need to suck on it
a little harder or essentially the
pressure drop across the pipe needs to
be higher
for both of those bubbles to come up and
that is essentially what happens here so
two resistors in series divide
the voltage across them
depending on the resistor value they
have
so without going to my screen i can just
use paper here
[Applause]
so that is
can you guys see this yes oh yes
okay so if we have
one resistor in series with other
resistor
and if they are so the sum of them
the voltage drop across one of them so
say there is a voltage drop across the
whole thing
this goes the opposite direction okay so
the voltage drop across one of them this
is r1
this is r2 will be
the resistor value of 1
over the sum of both of them
times the voltage here
so essentially the voltage drop across
one of them
will be the resistance of that one over
the sum of both of them
times the total voltage so
that is essentially what we are using
here um
to do this so in order to
get two volts out of this what
what do you guys think um the ratio
of these resistors supposed to be
essentially
this one resistor over the sum of
resistances
times nine should give us two
and that way we can find two divided by
nine should be the
ratio of these resistors and that is
essentially the resistor value that i
picked
it's random so you can pick many
different combinations that gives you
that ratio
which is i think 0.2
0.22 so to get that i chose 1.6
um kilo ohms resistor and a 5.6 kilo ohm
resistor
and as you guys can do the math 1.6
over the sum of both which is 7.2
will be
it's a little odd ratio but it will be
0.22 so that times 9 gives us the 2
volts
that we need and that is essentially
what i'm doing in the circuit right here
in here
yep so you guys can see the two yellow
resistors
those two yellow resistors one of them
is 1.6
the one that is horizontal is 1.6
and the other one is 5.6
and 1.6 over the sum of both of them
gives us the ratio and that connected to
the battery which is the blue
and red rail at the bottom right here
this rail is 9 volts and that divides it
and makes it 2 volts
and that's how we find the 2 volt from 9
volt battery
okay any questions
um yeah i have a question
yeah like when we
connect something so in
uh in the voltage divider we can
actually
connect something that has like fine
resistance
so we change effective resistance of one
of the resistors
uh in voltage divider how like
how can how do we need to pick
uh resistances of voltage divided
divided resistance
to make this effect lower
um which effect lower so you are you
talking about the two volts that at the
end we are getting you want to make that
lower
uh no i mean if i
like uh there are two volts
in the volt voltage divider if you don't
connect
anything to it but if we connect
something the
effective resistance of something we
connect and resist and
this resistor to which we connected the
scheme in parallel changes
and we once have two walls exactly two
walls
that is that is correct that is correct
if you
connect it in series it changes the
effective voltage drop or the effective
resistance and therefore the effective
voltage drop across one resistor
but so the way it is connected to this
circuit
in this diagram or in any other
situation when you're connecting
something you're usually connected in
parallel
so in parallel the voltage drop stays
the same across both of those parallel
things
ideally that would be the ideal scenario
but in real life
there is a slight drop across the
parallel um setup because of the losses
in the circuitry and all the other
things
but in in theory when you connect things
in parallel the voltage drop across both
of them will stay the same
and um that's why
the led circuit is connected in parallel
to the 1.6 volts
or 1.6 kilo ohm resistor and therefore
the voltage drop across that resistor
stays two volts only
uh what would happen if too much current
runs do
yeah led so the led
is essentially a piece of material that
has electrons at certain transition
states
so the way it emits emit light or emits
light
is essentially activation of those
electrons and that's how it emits light
and it requires certain energy level
to cause the activation to happen if
there's too much
energy and most of the commercial ones
they just break so the led just breaks
and if you put too much current through
it it just breaks and it will not work
again
which essentially means that the
material whatever they are using in
there
um just melts down or the energy for it
is too much
and some of the other cases um
if you put too much current um through a
thin wire um especially when it's
it doesn't have a heat sink in any other
way it will just melt down
so in short answer led just breaks and
you will not be able to use it again
yeah um i hope that was clear
you can use it in your own projects one
of the projects i actually made was
a um a clock i made a
clock for my room i don't have it here
right now but it was
a clock that was controlled by by an
arduino which is just a microprocessor
and each of the 12 numbers on the clock
were leds
and it would turn on depending on the
hour and the minute of the day
it was so you can use um a simple
calculations like this like
ohm's law in practice to find the
resistor values for the
different leds that you will be using in
that case the clock for example
you